bien mesdames messieurs monsieur le
ministre merci de votre présence
peut-être avant de débuter cette
commission et de vous donner la parole
dans quelques
[Musique]
instants vous dire que vous allez porter
seul la charge de présenter l'ensemble
des budgets liés au ministre au
ministère de
l'Intérieur et donc vous faire part
simplement d'un regret mais qui ne vise
pas évidemment que le ministre
l'intérieur et et les autres ministres
ne soient pas là ou n'ai pas pu être là
on peut comprendre les chosees
naturellement mais ça nous embête un peu
tout de même contte tenu de l'importance
des budgets qui sont en cause et sans
doute certain nombre de questions qui
doivent être posées mais néanmoins nous
respectons la mission qui est la
vôtre et donc on va vous laisser la
parole immédiatement sachant que sur la
partie très directe qui vous concerne de
l'outrem il y aura sans doute des
questions évidemment importantes enfin
je l'imagine mais pour le reste bien sûr
vous ferez la présentation ti du
gouvernement ce qui est parfaitement
normal mais il y aura sans doute aussi
des questions voilà monsieur le ministre
mais vous avez on est retransmis ou pas
oui l'audition est retransmise donc sur
le site internet du Sénat voilà monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs tout d'abord je
tiens à excuser l'absence de Gérald
dermanin monsieur le Président mais je
crois qu'il y a une bonne raison que je
tiens à vous livrer immédiatement mais
vous connaissez parce que je connais
votre perspicacité et vous savez qu'il
est auditionné en ce moment même à
l'Assemblée nationale sur un texte sur
lequel vous avez beaucoup travailler C
Tex notamment concernant
l'immigration le ministre délégué que je
suis à l'outreem est pour autant
rattaché au pôle intérieur c'est raison
pour laquelle il m'a demandé d'être
devant vous mais je suis entouré d'une
équipe formidable qui m'aidera à
répondre de des questions que vous PZ me
poser après un propos liminaire si mieux
autorisé et vous dire que je seraiis
extrêmement attentif à ce que on puisse
connaissant votre exence naturelle et
c'est normal quand on est parlementaire
que l'on puisse vous apporter tous ces
élémentsl donc vous dire je suis très
heureux d'être devant vous vous dire que
sur cette mission immigration asile
intégration administration générale et
territoriale de l'État c'est ce sont des
missions extraordinairement importantes
puisque jamais je dis bien jamais l'État
n'a eu autant besoin de sécurité nos
compatriotes besoin de sécurité et qu'il
fallait déployer des moyens pour cela
alors évidemment il y a les moyens
budgétaires et puis il y a celles et
ceux qui au quotidien mettent en œuvre
et bien cette action de de protection
des populations ces femmes ces hommes
qui dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles on le voit ont pour mission
essentielle celle de faire en sorte que
l'ordre publique puisse régner alors
vous savez parfaitement qu'en 2023 C été
un rendez-vous essentiel avec avec cette
fameuse lopmie avec 15 milliards d'euros
à la clé sur 5 ans 15 milliards d'euros
à la clé sur 5 ans pour les c'est donc
mieux protéger nos Français et avec une
exigence de faire en sorte qu'on ne soit
pas uniquement en affichage des crédits
et le vieux parlementaire que je suis
c'est que c'est l'exécution qui compte
et sachez bien que malgré la
revalorisation du point d'Al qui est
bien normal et de l'inflation et la
prise sous plafond et bien ça veut dire
que il y aura bien cette somme là qui
sera consacrée sur les moyens de
protection des Françis avec quatre
priorités renforcer la présence des
forces de sécurité intérieure sur la
voie publique et on peut le constater
chaque jour lutter contre le terrorisme
c'est un combat de longue haleine et qui
faudra malheureusement poursuivre encore
pendant de longues années conforter
l'administration territoriale je
prendrai quelques exemples et puis le
grand rendez-vous que chacun attend
c'est celui des Jeux Olympiques des Jeux
paralympiques pour lesquel en
intergouvernemental et bien vous savez
que la mobilisation est totale alors
pour les menaces diverses multiples il y
a un effort sur les forces de sé
sécurité intérieur partout sur le
territoire déjà sur la sur la voie
publique on a doublé je dis bien doublé
sur la voie
publique la présence de force de
sécurité notamment par la fin des gardes
statiques c'était un débat permanent en
en regardant évidemment que ces forces
statiques n'étaient pas suffisamment
efficaces et donc il y a une
substitution de ces personnels actifs
par des personnels administratif je
crois que c'est une demande qui était
réitérée par nos deux chambres et le
ministère et en particulier Géral
dermanin il a donné mais s une vraie
crédibilité donc le chiffre c'est
2850 force de Sécur intériure nouvelle
des FC qui ont été déployés en 2023
c'estd que sur 5 ans ce chiffre mérite
d'être souligné 7400 en plus sur 5 ans
j'ai pas oublié un temps où de les
années 2007 à 2012 c'était -
8950 - 8950 vous voyez que l'effort là
qui est en train d'être fait par ce
gouvernement est essentiel à cela
s'ajoute 11 créations 7 de gendarmerie
nationale 4 de des police national c'est
1640 personnels et le financement de
1266 équivalent en plein pour les ce
qu'on appelle les circonscription de
sécurité publique prioritaire donc
police nationale sur les deux premières
années ce renforcement de notre présence
passe aussi par un afferblissement de
l'ancrage territorial l'ancrage
territorial vous savez ce sont les
brigades qui ont été annoncées 239 sur
50 en concentation avec les ÉU avec un
maillage qui pour lequel l'outremè n'a
pas été oublié je ça devant la
présidente de la délégation des rem
parce qu'il y a 22 sur les outres alors
vous savez qu'il y a à la fois des
brigades fixes ou des brigades mobiles
et surtout un déclenchement rapide parce
que dès 2023 les premières ont été
lancées et 24 c'est une très grande
accélération et vous avez bien compris
qu'au travers de ces brigades je crois
que ce sont les Français qui demande
simplement avoir de l'uniforme voir du
bleu d'avoir cette protection au
quotidien et bien c'est un moyen me
semble-t-il par ces deux dimensions de
répondre à leur attente alors sur les
outre m merci monsieur le Président fait
référence c'est plus mon champ quotidien
bien vous dire que les efforts de
sécurité c'est une exigence absolue on
voit malheureusement et on constate
encore que trop souvent malgré des
déploiements considérables ces trois
dernières années depuis que le ministre
de l'intérieur est en responsabilité
1400 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires à l'heure où je vous
parle 21 escadrons de gendarme mobile
c'està-dire 20 % de l'ensemble des
effectifs nationaux qui sont déployés
sur l'ensemble des territoires
ultramarins finalement on peut citer la
Guyane c'était Mayotte mais il n'y a pas
que ce territoire là ça veut dire qu'on
a souhaité faire un effort considérable
de même il y a une opération harpi qui
mobilise comme vous le savez de nombreux
fonctionnaires et qui est pourtant une
opération tout à fait indispensable et
je disais 22 créations utreem et sur la
seule année 2324 à cheval sur les 2 ans
ce sont 8 je d ça pour la présidente de
la délégation extrêmement attentive et
naturellement sur ces question de
sécurité qui sont très preignantes dans
les territoires ultramarins pour lesquel
vous vous voyez qu'il y a eu un
engagement
considérable ensuite pour l'émission
ultremre peut-être un mot puisqu'il y a
180 millions d'euros de plus alors 7 %
voyez en étant très honnête monsieur le
Président comme j'ai fait l'exercice
devant votre collègue à l'Assemblée
nationale ce donc 7 % si vous retranchez
l'inflation c'est 4,4 % de moyens
complémentaires et en plus à la sortie
du 493 ça sera encore 90 million d'euros
que l'on va déployer donc voyez que je
souligne ce chiffre parce qu'on va
franchir le niveau de 3 milliards
d'euros d'intervention pour les utremèes
mais en
interministériel tout périmètre
ministériel confondu on n'est pas loin
de 23 milliards d'euros 3 milliards
d'euros simplement il y a 5 ans on était
à 2 milliards dem regarder un peu les
périmètres ministériels dans lesquels il
y a eu une si forte augmentation je
crois qu'ils ne sont pas très nombreux
ça tmoine là encore d'une volonté du
ministère de l'Intérieur et des outr mes
de faire cet effort
particulier alors sur les outrem
peut-être pour rentrer quelques secondes
dans les détails si on prend la
politique du logement la fameuse ligne
budgétaire unique qui attiendra prè de
292 millions d'euros mais je vais être
très honnête cette remarque m'a été
faite à l'Assemblée on revient au niveau
de 2013 on a eu des sous-consommations
mais c'est 50 millions en plus pour 2024
c'est hors quartier politique de la
ville 20 millions d'euros
complémentaires pour les logements
sociaux c'est des aides de l'ANA qui
passent de 30 à 50 %. c'est des aides
qui seront apportées sur les logements
pas simplement neufs
mais également ancien en défiscalisation
qui nous permettent d'être au
rendez-vous c'est les fameux contrats de
convergence transformation vous savez
que les contrats qui l'ont signe avec
les territoires qui augmentent pour la
période 2427 de 400 millions d'euros on
passe de 2 milliard 4 à 2liard 8 ça veut
donc dire que il y a un effort dans
différentes dimensions et puis je
n'oublie pas le Corum tout ce que c'est
que le Corum le fameux soutien aux
communes en difficulté pour lesquels
nous nous avions signé 9 contrats dans
l'année 21 22 dans le lancement 12 dans
l'année 22 23 et on continuera et et on
continuera fortement puisque il y a
encore des des attentes des demandes et
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
marche bien d'une notion de
corresponsabilisation pour les uns et
pour les autres et puis deux choses
encore pour terminer le chapitre sur les
utrem une aide qui sera très
sensiblement augmentée en
2024 c'est d'abord la continuité
territoriale interrogé il y a quelques
minutes à la EMBL sur cette question
nous passons de 70 à 93 million d'euros
et les jeunes primau étudiants dès les
vacances de Noël là dans un mois pouront
rentrer qu'il soit boursier ou non
boursier avec un billet pris en charge
dans le cadre de cette continuité
territoriale et avec une autre chose
c'est qu'on a élargi les publics domaine
culturel domaine naturellement sportif
pour les sportifs de ha niveau bref et
puis le demandeurs d'emploi et ceux qui
sont également en reconverstion
professionnelle qui pourront santt un
changement de souhait de vie
professionnelle bénéficier de ce
soutienl là donc voyez que ce sont des
efforts avec d'ailleurs des moyens
déployés encore plus importants pour la
fameuse agence qui permet de gérer tout
cela au quotidien un dernier mot et ça
ça concerne les collectivités lorsqu'on
est signatrice sénateur c'est un sujet
majeur c'est le fameux FEI de cet
acronyme qui explique c'est le fond
exceptionnel d'investissement qui va
augmenter et d'ailleurs monsieur le
Président il a nom d'amendements
j'imagine qui seront déposés au Sénat
que nous accepterons avec bonheur pour
faire en sorte qu'on augmente le soutien
aux communes ce FEI a montré toute sa
pertinence il était à 110 millions
d'euros il y a déjà eu des amendements
qui ont été acceptés à l'Assemblée et je
seraai favorable avec le gouvernement ce
qu'on aille plus loin parce que là
encore c'est un moyen me semble-t-il
avec le soutien technique apporté aux
communes soutien technique apporté aux
communes qui passera en 2024 de 10 à 20
millions d'euros c'est comment apporter
une ingéerie pour aller plus loin alors
j'en reviens à la sécurité naturellement
pour vous dire que sur les
investissements qui qui ont été annoncés
très précisément je tiens à vous donner
les chiffres c'est plus de 4 4800
véhicules légers pour la police
nationale la gendarmerie nationale à qui
en
avec on peut dire qu'en 2024 ça sera un
chiffre de 3600 pour 130 millions
d'euros donc vous voyez en 23 4800 et en
24 3600 et puis y a le plan caméra
piéton ça sera donc 35000 caméras qui
sont installé à la fin de l'année
2024 suite aux annonces du président de
la République il y a un amendement qui
qui a été déposé sur le renforcement des
moyens dédiés à la sécurité civile je
tiens à l on a eu des comme vous savez
des incendies de forêt considérable et
donc ça sera pas moins de 140 millions
d'euros qui sont inscrits donc je crois
que ça permettra avec la création de
cette 4e unité d'instruction et de
sécurité civile qui devrait voir le jour
à Libourne dès 2024 la création de 163
ETP je donne le chiffres précis mais 39
millions de pactes capacitair 32
millions canadaire je crois que c'est
était attendu depuis longtemps et puis
23 millions pour la location de moyens
aériens parce que quelquefois nous avons
recours à des locations de moyens
aériens des bombardiers d'eau en
particulier des avions quelquefois et
euh donc je crois que vous voyez qu'en
matière de sécurité civile 2024 sera une
inflexction très forte mais l'exigence
c'est qu'on soit au rendez-vous ces
incendies sont là malgré les moyens de
détection d'anticipation malgré les
textes initiatives qui ont été voté eu
nous devons être à la hauteur de ces
enjeux
ensuite pour la flotte d'hélicoptères
c'est une question est un peu redondante
depuis longtemps c'est 40 nouveaux
hélicoptères qui son qui sont en cours
d'acquisition et c'est un engagement qui
est signé à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros donc chacun a bien compris là
encore que c'était un élément
indispensable notamment dans la lutte
contre les incendies pour répondre à la
cyberciminalité 1500 cyber patrouillant
ont été recrutés donc on augmente de 50
% le par rapport à l'existant un appel
numérique d'urgence le 17 cyber qui a
été mis en place et puis des
investissements importants sont toutes
prévues pour moderniser les services
numériques accessibles aux citoyens
après les succès de Pho CZ ça sera une
vis plainte et le portail mass sécurité
qui sera utile et qui permettra de
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle le
dernier kilomètre de l'application de la
loi parce que malheureusement on
s'aperçoit que l'efficacité elle est au
rendez-vous que si on va toucher la
personne en
direct sur le ministère sur le
réarmement contue de l'administration
générale les territorial de l'État on a
connu vous l'avez connu monsieur le
Président en tant que parlementaire les
années où malheureusement l'état perdit
de ses moyens à la fois d'intervention
de présence territorial et vous savez
qu'on a commencé à inspirer cette
spirale spirale de façon assez forte
d'abord sur laalopmie trois grandes
priorités qui sont développé d'abord la
première c'est renforcer nos capacités
numériques et cyber avec les réseaux
radio du futur adosser à l'agence de
communication et qui s'appelle l'acmos
deuxièmement réarmer l'état territorial
on va créer 350 emplois 110 créations
d'emplois précisément en 24 pour
continuer à soutenir les missions
préfecturales les plus en tension et
notamment une euh qui est souvent
discutée dans les commissions des lois
comme ici c'est C de tites de séjour des
étrangers gestion de crise et accueil
d'usager de même on augmentera les
actions de prévention de la délinquante
la radicalisation renforçant notamment
la vidéoprotection euh 25 millions
d'euros en 24 contre 22 en 23 donc vous
voyez que là encore il y a un effort
substantiel de plus de 10 %
sur la création de souspréfecture 8
millions d'euros qui seront déployés en
24 F un temps où on fermé les
gendarmeries on fermé les
sous-préfectures mais là on réouvre les
gendarmerie on réouvre les
sous-préfectures qui n'était pas ma joie
de voir l'autre jour en Guyane la
réouverture d'une sous-préfecture avec
une jeune sous-préfette qui prenait ses
responsabilités quelque part sur un
territoire comme la Guyane qui est grand
comme le Portugal c'est un signe très
fort de l'État et puis bien sûr des
laabilisation de certaines
souspréfectures en maison France service
je crois que l'utilité des maisons
France service le qui a pu être
constitué depuis quelques années et
quelque chose un outil très apprécié par
nos concitoyens et rappelle la présence
forte de l'État au plus près de de
chacune et chacun et notamment très
attaché étant un territoire rural dans
les territoires ruraux bien sûr les Jeux
Olympiques jeuxlym paraolympiques la
Coupe du monde du rugby je crois que
c'est passé dans dans des très belles
conditions il y a eu des opérations
conduite à la demande du ministre donc
4800 opérations zéro délinquence alors
il y a eu beaucoup d'interpellations
c'est vrai 781 interpellations euh 475
gardes- à vue vous voyez des drones
parce que maintenant on a nouveau
dangers qui arrivve avec des drones qui
peuvent être présents et qui peuvent
nuire naturellement au dispositifs de
sécurité et puis les Jeux Olympique je
le rappelle en deux lignes c'est un
enjeu considérable parce que d'abord sur
la durée euh 5 semaines deuxièmement sur
le nombre de sites où il y aura des
compétitions 30 sites euh 200 signations
10000 athlètes nous serons sous les
projecteurs euh du monde entier donc on
doit faire de de cette fête du sport
absolument merveilleuse un outil
d'attractivité de développement
économique mais on doit le faire dans
les conditions de sécurité absolue et
pour cela ce sont pas moins de 35000 je
dis bien 35000 forces de sécurité
intérieure qui pendant ces 6 semaines
seront déployés avec un budget mais oui
parce que si on dit déploiement des
forces sécurité intérieure à ce
niveau-là 200 millions d'euros qui sont
budgetés pour cette très belle opération
enfin sur le budget de la mission
immigration asile intégration pour 2024
c'est un budget en augmentation de plus
de 7 % monsieur le Président à hauteur
de 2,2 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement donc ça représente pas moins de
10 % de l'ensemble des crédits du
ministère sur le périmètre de laalopmie
cette augmentation je crois est très
sensible elle inclut naturellement les
crédits issus de laalopmie pour la
période 22 27 109 million d'euros y
compris ce du plan CRA centre de
rétention d' administratif 3000 elle
marque notre volonté vous l'avez compris
il vient d' avoir un débat assez long
ici au Sénat maintenant il va démarrer à
l'Assemblée sur la question de
l'immigration donc la maîtrise des flux
immigratoire lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière garantir l'exercice du droit
d'asile et renforcer l'intégration des
étrangers en situation régulière dit ce
qu'on appelle les primo arrivant il
s'inscrit pleinement dans le casadre de
la lopmie avec une programmation
budgétaire inédite en 5 ans on aura fait
progresser les crédit affectés à la
mission donc à la politique migratoire
intéressant de le comparer sur les
précédentes années de façon crois assez
inégalé vous avz bien compris qu'une
politique migratoire naturellement qui
doit être au rendez-vous et qui doit
être plus efficace mais pour autant il y
a une deuxième jambe on être équilibré
doit être aussi plus humaine et vous
connaissez parfaitement par au Sénat je
crois que le texte initial du
gouvernement a sensiblement évolué et
par l'article 4 en particulier qui a été
voté dans cette maison la réponse se
trouve je crois pleinement apporté enfin
dernier mot sur les budgets des
collectivités territoriales au moment où
le le Salon des Maires et a lieu cette
semaine à Paris donc la DGF donc 220
millions d'euros d'augmentation ce qui
fait que sur les deux dernières années
on a un peu plus de 500 millions d'euros
d'augmentation je rappelle à descin que
j'ai connu les années 2012-27 où on
avait 13,5 milliards de BA de notation
collectivité territoriale faut toujours
comparer les choses permet de d'avoir un
bon miroir de voir où est la volonté
politique et où est le chemin ensuite
100 millions de de DSR 90 millions
d'euros de dessu et et 30 millions
d'euros pour les dotations
d'intercommunalité sur les délivrances
des titres sécurisés j'ai été maire
pendant 16 ans donc c'est quelque chose
VO un nouveau sénateur du Loiré que je
connais qui a été mer longtemps
d'attendre 6 semaines 2 mois 3 mois 3
mois et demi ben écoutez on est revenu à
15 à 18 jours c'est une volonté c'est
difficile ça veut dire mettre des moyens
moyens humains les former avoir des
dispositifs qui fonctionnent avoir des
créneaux horair suffisamment larges et
je crois que l' on a progressé en tout
cas faut rester sur ce niveau de prog
prression donc c'est pas moins de 100
millions d'euros sur les tit sécurisé
qui seront mis en 2024 et puis en face
il y a ce je sais que Dominique fort ma
collègue est très attaché vous sa que so
les élus très souvent agressés vous avez
devant vous un ministre qui a été menacé
de mort trois fois donc je vais pouvoir
en parler très librement on a un fond un
fond qui est en train de svrir de 5
d'euros et avec cette fameuse loi du 7
juillet on va quand même faire de
reconnaître que enfin on va s'occuper
avec efficacité des menaces brandi cha
toujours plus nombreuses vis-à-vis des
maires qui pourtant sont les piliers de
la République sont en première ligne et
sont ceux qui au quotidien en tant
qu'agent de l'État sont là pour apporter
du service public sur les budgets des
collectivités je rappelle que c'est 11,7
milliards d'euros dont la TVA à hauteur
de 7 milliards 1 et le soutient
l'investissement 4,6 milliards d'euros
donc avec une je crois notamment les
fonds verts Fonds vert qui avait été
annoncé à hauteur de 2 milliards l'année
dernière par Christophe Béchu et l'on
passe à à 2 milliards 4 2 milliard 5
pardon donc vous l'avez bien compris que
c'est un verdissement du budget
d'ailleurs dans les dotations
habituelles que vous connaissez tous par
cœur une partie sera flécher en
direction de la transition écologique 20
à 30 % selon ces différentes dotations
de manière à ce que au-delà des mots on
soit dans la réalisation dans la
concrétisation de la transformation
progressive de l'économie pour qu'elle
réponde à cet enjeu de transition
écologique enfin les plus fragiles ne
sont pas oubliés pour terminer mon
propos monsieur le Président notamment
renforcer l'attractivité de tous les
territoires on aura une simplification
des zonages au sein des France ruralités
revitalisation c'était une demande qui
étit je crois formulé en tout cas
département dont je suis élu cette
demande revenez souvent déconcentration
parce que la déconcentration c'est
s'adapter plus et et faire ce qui me
paraît plus important de ne pas avoir
uniquement un qualque parisien mais
d'être en capacité d'être au plus proche
de celles et ceux qui sont tous les
jours en action les double niveau pour
tenir compte des territoires qui ont
besoin d'un accompagnement renforcé et
puis renforcement du suivi de
l'évaluation du dispositif voilà je sais
que Dominique fort de toute façon aura
beaucoup de plaisir à revenir attacher
comme elle l' aux collectivités
territoriales à répondre à l'ensemble
des questions des des sénateurs dont on
sait que ce sont avant tout tous les
représentants de tous ceux qui sont élus
dans les territoires voilà monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs les les
sénateurs le propos liminire que je
souhaitais pouvoir vous adresser au nom
de Géral nman merci Monsieur le Ministre
alors il plusieurs demandes
d'intervention nousons commencer par
Monsieur tan Mahamed Souali puis ensuite
madame la Présidente cuceran et puis
Madame Françoise Dumont Madame Nathalie
deâre après c'est noté allons-y mon
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le le
ministre pour
vos vos explications
euh j'aurai deux séries de de questions
une question sur la la sécurité
euh à Mayotte et puis deux questions sur
les les crédits outrum qui viennent
d'être adopté par la commission des des
lois ce matin
euh sur la partie sécurité vous avez
évoqué euh l'augmentation des escadrons
et c'est une réalité au passage j'en
profite pour encore une fois
euh souligner euh le le début de succès
et l'espoir suscité à Mayotte par euh
l'opération mon bouchou euh mais forc de
constater que en pleine crise de l'eau
crise de l'eau qui là aussi a a donné
lieu à des à des débuts de de de répones
euh
intéressant pendant cette crise la
violence a repris de de plus belles et
notamment une violence perpétrée par des
bandes de jeunes qui se donneent
rendez-vous sur les les réseaux sociaux
pour aller dans les villages et et euh
commettre des saccages brûler euh des
voitures euh et et des habitations
euh les les Maoris ressentent ceci euh
euh très durement vous êtes venu à
plusieurs reprises à Mayotte
euh pour voir dans dans quelles
conditions euh de de difficultés de
souffrance euh euh sont vive vive la
population
euh ce qui peine euh les les les les
habitants de ces villages c'est que en
réponse euh à ces méfets
euh des du gaz lacrymogène est dispersé
de façon indiscriminé dans dans les
villages dans dans les quartiers dans
lesquels vivent faut-il le rappeler des
personnes vulnérables des personnes
âgées des des enfants
euh je n'avais pas forcément prévu de
vous posez cette question aujourd'hui
mais c'est euh à l'occasion de de de de
de vos propos sur l'augmentation des des
des forces de l'ordre c'est une bonne
chose mais ne pensez-vous pas que il
faille changer la doctrine
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre et
que la dispersion de gaz lacrymogène ne
peut pas être une réponse satisfaisante
à ce euh à cette recrut d'esens des des
des violences en tout cas c'est la
demande que je je formule
euh les les les à chaque fois qu'il y a
ce genre euh d'événement et pas plus
tard qu'avant-hier le soir les habitants
appellent les élus pour dire mais à quoi
ça sert de nous disperser euh de nous
asperger de de gaz larymogène alors que
c'est voyou une fois euh yant commis les
fait mais partent et le temps que les
gaz lacrymogène arrivent sur place ils
sont ne sont plus ne sont plus là déjà
donc c'est plus une demande euh qu'une
question de changement de doctrine afin
de ne pas euh doublement triplement
pénaliser les les villageois
ensuite sur la partie crédit outremire
comme je l'ai précisé tout à l'heure la
commission des lois a examiné ce matin
les crédit donner un avis favorable je
l'en remercie encore
euh puisque cette hausse de crédit va
financer et renforcer la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne euh l'insertion
professionnelle et la continuité
territoriale certaines interrogations
demeurent cependant euh en ce qui
concerne d'abord la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne euh j'ai été alors été
alerté par des problèmes de
sous-consommation des crédits finançant
la la LBU 150 logements seraient encore
insalubre en notre mare pourriez-vous
monsieur le ministre me dire quelle
mesure vous envisager de prendre afin de
garantir le décaissement de la totalité
des crédits dédiés à la ressorption de
l'habitat insalubre et l'accélération
des livraisons de logements neuf par
ailleurs l'année dernière votre collègue
le ministre Christophe Béchu s'était
engagé à prendre des mesures pour
remédier pour remédier au au manque
d'adaptation de certaines mesures aux
spécificités des territoires ultramarins
et notamment du filet de sécurité visant
à protéger les collectivités de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie euh un an
plus tard force de constater que les
mesures annoncées n'ont pas été prises
euh puisque seulement 19 collectivités
ultramarines ont bénéficié de ce
dispositif depuis sa mise en place pour
un montant de 14 millions d'euros aussi
et c'est là ma ma seconde question sur
les crédits quelle mesure entendezv
prendre pour remédier à cette situation
et enfin adapter les dispositions
nationaux aux spécificités des autres
maires je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente
cuckerman oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre tout
d'abord permettez-moi en en préalable de
de déplorer tout de même l'absence du
ministre de l'intérieur de la Ministre
chargée des collectivités territoriales
et je sais Monsieur le Ministre que le
gouvernement bien évidemment est une
équipe et que vous êtes en capacité de
représenter tous ces gens-là mais mais
je trouve cependant que pour une
audition qui vise à préparer le projet
de loi de finan et notamment les
missions qui concernent la sécurité qui
concern l'asile l'immigration les
collectivités territoriales les
outres-mes l'administration générale
territoriale de l'État et
cetera je je pense que plusieurs voies e
été pertinentes et en tout cas nous
aurit certainement permis au sénateurs
que nous sommes de pouvoir rentrer dans
beaucoup plus de détails puisque bien
évidemment le le premier travail au sein
d'une commission n'est pas simplement de
faire du déclaratif ni de votre part ni
de notre part mais de pouvoir avancer et
et tenter de cheminer ensemble donc je
le regrette certainement la date n'est
pas la bonne mais à chaque fois elle
tombe le mardi du Congrès des Maires ce
n'est pas une nouveauté d'avoir cette
audition à ce moment-là et les uns et
les autres faisont en sorte en tout cas
de pouvoir y être euh cependant
euh sur l'administra la la mission
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État je veux et névitablement vous
l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre par les chiffres que vous avez
donné tout d'abord saluer le
renforcement des moyens humains qui sont
dédiés pour ce projet de loi de finances
à l'administration territoriale de
l'État et qui inévitablement intervient
après une une décennie de de coûpt
budgétaire drastique et et parfois même
d'augmentation en
trompleœuil vous l'avez dit ce sont 232
créations de PO dont 110 pour renforcer
les missions préfectorales en tension et
elles sont nombreuses cependant il met
malheureusement un possible que
considérer de considérer que ce schéma
d'emploi offre une réponse satisfaisante
à la crise profonde que traverse l'état
de
proximité et qui d'ailleurs s'exprime
régulièrement par un certain nombre de
tensions dans nos territoires et qui a
vu effectivement les ses effectifs
fondre de 14 % entre 2010 et
2021 le projet de loi de finance pour
2024 propose ne propose qu'une
augmentation de 0,41 % des effectifs de
l'administration territoriale de l'État
évolution dont nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire au regard du bilan de la
décennie passée d'une part et des défis
que l'État territorial doit relever a
commencé dès cette année euh à
l'approche des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 d'autre part parmi
ces défis il y a également le maintien
d'une très forte demande de titre
sécurisés euh qui fait craindre
l'aggravation d'ailleurs des
disfonctionnement constaté dans
l'exercice de cette mission bien que la
situation ne soit plus à cette heure
aussi dramatique qu'elle ne l'a été en
2022 cependant et peut-être de manière
un peu plus précise que vous avez fait
dans vos propos liminires
comment est-ce que vous
entendez pouvoir per en tout cas à ces
délais et tenter le plus le mieux
possible de réduire les délais de
délivrance ne craignez-vous pas
d'ailleurs qu'une nouvelle mise
sousension de la chaîne de production du
fait notamment de l'identité numérique
régalienne qui nécessitera pour chaque
citoyen pour pouvoir en bénéficier de
disposer de la nouvelle version de la
carte nationale d'identité donc nous
allons passer
de du drame français qu'il y a eu il y a
maintenant un peu plus d'un an
c'est-à-dire une perte massive des
cartes d'identité par nos concitoyens et
soudain à très certainement une nouvelle
perte massive et soudaine pour beaucoup
de nos concitoyens pour pouvoir
bénéficier compris de de ces services
donc bon voilà sur sur ce point-là
deuxième point qui est bien évidemment
de pouvoir dresser un premier bilan de
l'expérimentation de la certification
des comptes par les mairies puisque cela
ne concerne aujourd'hui qu'une un nombre
réduit de communes volontaes comme toute
expérimentation mais comment est-ce que
vous entendez pouvoir le déployer et
enfin est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
est-ce que vous savez évaluer combien
d'électeurs auront la possibilité
d'établir une procuration de manière
totalement dématérialiser en vue des
élections européennes de juin
2024 je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente madame
Dumont merci monsieur le Président
bonsoir monsieur le ministre je vais
vous parler sécurité Civile Monsieur le
Ministre puisque la commission des lois
a examiné mercredi dernier les crédits
du programme 161 visant donc aux moyens
nationaux de la sécurité civile nous
avons émis un amis un avis favorable à
l'adoption de ces crédit et avons saluer
l'effort budgétaire conséquent qui a été
effectué ces deux dernières années
toutefois vous vous en doutez bien ça
n'est pas un chèque en blanc et de
nombreuses interrogations demeurent sur
plus plusieurs sujets nous avons adopté
ainsi deux amendements de crédit que je
défendrai au nom de mes collègues il
concern d'une part l'acquisition de deux
hélicoptères lourds promis par le
Président de la République le 28 octobre
2022 et d'autre part la consommation
intégrale des autorisations d'engagement
destinées au pacte capacitaire que nous
avons voté dans la précédente loi de
finance et dont le calendrier est pour
le moins opaque mais nous en débattrons
la la semaine prochaine chaîne je
souhaite pour l'heure vous interroger
sur d'autres sur deux sujets très précis
en premier lieu pourriez-vous nous
expliciter euh le la position du
ministère de l'Intérieur quant au
dimensionnement du plan de
renouvellement et d'extension de la
flotte de canadaire qui nous a été une
fois aussi de plus annoncé l'année
dernière vos services m'ont confirmé
explicitement que le calendrier initial
annoncé par le président de la
République à savoir le renouvellement
intégral de nos 12 canadaires et l'achat
de quatre canadaires supplémentaires
d'ici la fin du quinquena était
irréalisable contte tenu des difficultés
de mise en place d'une chaîne de
production ils m'ont alors indiqué que
dans un dans un scénario je cite
optimiste les quatre appareils
permettant d'étendre la flotte à 16
appareils pourrait être livré pour le
premer en 2027 et pour le dernier au
cours de la première moitié de la
décennie 2030 ils sont en revanche
restés très évasifs quant à la passation
d'une commande même tardive de 12
appareils permettant de renouveler
notreotte notre flotte actuelle et vous
comprendrez donc bien facilement ma vive
préoccupation sur le sujet face à cette
apparente inertie alors que les délaaiis
de livraison se chiffrent en décenni ma
question est donc la suivante le plan de
renouvellement de notre flotte de
canader je par parle du plan de
renouvellement et non du plan
d'extension est-il toujours d'actualité
et pouvez-vous vous engager sur sa mise
en œuvre effective ma seconde question
porte sur la méthode de construction du
budget opéré par le ministère de
l'Intérieur à deux reprise l'année
dernière le gouvernement a déposé des
amendements de crédit sur le programme
161 l'augmentant très significativement
de l'ordre de 40 %. à nouveau cette
année un amendement gouvernemental
représentant un tiers des autorisations
d'engagement du programme et qui ne
précisait pas la ventilation détaillée
des crédits a été adopté en octobre à
l'Assemblée nationale afin de financer
des mesures pourtant annoncé en octobre
2022 par le président donc il y a plus
d'un an une telle méthode de
construction du budget pour des mesures
connues de longue date est à mes yeux
vraiment insatisfaisante au regard de
l'impératif de sincérité budgétaire et
du respect du débat parlementaire
d'aoutant que ces sommes débloquées ne
font l'objet d'aucune évaluation dans le
projet annuel de performance qui est
annexè au projet de loi de finances
pouvez-vous donc vous engager autant que
possible à de recour de recourir à
éviter pardon de recourir à ce procédé
lors des prochaines années merci merci
madame la sénatrice Madame Nathalie de
lâre merci Président je je vais poser
deux questions en lien avec ma mission
de de rapport sur la Direction de
l'action du gouvernement et deux sur mon
département
eu je souhaite vous soumettre quelques
questions sur la coordination des
actions de de cybersécurité du ministère
de l'intérieur avec les services du
Premier ministre dont font partie
viginom et lany notamment en 2024 le
service de vigilance et de protection
contre les ingérances Numériques
étrangères viginom donc bénéfficiera de
10 transferts d'emploi en provenance de
votre ministère si le service peut
détecter des ingérences il n'est pas
chargé de la réponse répressive et plus
généralement des mesures de
contre-influence ou de contre-ingérence
par ailleurs le ministère de l'Intérieur
a affirmé que la DGSI demeure seul
compétente pour attribuer les
manipulations à des puissances
étrangères ainsi quel réseau de
coopération était mis en place afin
d'articuler les actions de ces
différents services deuxème
interrogation sur le pilotage des action
de cybersécurité auprès des
collectivités territoriales ces
dernières étant victime de 23 % des
attaques de ransongiciiciel
envisagez-vous un plan national de
financement pour répondre à la
vulnérabilité de leur système
d'information et quel acteur pourrait le
cas échéant porter cette stratégie
nationale d'envergure l'ancy et les
services déconcentrés du du ministère de
l'intérieur ou les services
décentralisés et qui l'Anci nous ayant
parlé de l'estimation d'une enveloppe à
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
pour les moyens financiers t quant aux
moyens humains la DGPN a souligné dans
un article de presse que les enquêteurs
les mieux formés en cybersécurité
tendent à se diriger vers le secteur
privé en raison d'une rémunération
jusqu'à trois fois plus élevée ainsi
quelles réflexions sont en cours pour
recruter et fidéliser des experts dans
le
domaine avez-vous envisagé des actions
communes de formation et de recrutement
avec LC le CNCT ou d'autres
administrations
concernées deux questions plus
particulières sur mon
département nous avons vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure l'usique de de de
Libourne est-ce que vous pouvez me
confirmer les crédits 2024 pour engager
les travaux euh et puis en deuxème
question vous avez parlé des Jeux
Olympiques moi je vais parler des
dommages collatéraux de des Jeux
Olympiques sur nos territoires avec la
surveillance par
les les CRS mns de nos plages où il est
impensable que nous n'ayons pas ce
renfort pendant cette période estivale
je vous rappelle nous avons eu encore
des morts euh malheureusement du au bah
dans
l'Atlantique et pour nous il est
impératif de de pouvoir compter sur ce
soutien Gérald damanin s'était engagé
euh à réunir les maires en septembre il
y a eu d'autres priorités normalement il
devrait conduire cette réunion est-ce
que vous pouvez m'assurer que cette
réunion sera conduite avec les maires
pour pouvoir les rassurer en la matière
merci merci sénatrice moi je peut-être
une question complémentaire qui touche à
l'autreem et en particulier il me semble
avoir compris mais je vis pas certain
paradis de bêtises que pour ce qui
concerne l'aide à l'ingénierie locale on
passerait de 10 à 24 millions d'euros et
c'est une erreur de compréhension 20 20
millions d'euros la question de fond
c'est très bien pour le le volume
financier quelle méthode pour que ça se
fasse réellement s'il vous plaît merci
écoutez monsieur le ministre vous avez
la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord pour répondre au
sénateur t permettra de de démarrer
naturellement par par Mayotte je le
remercie d'avoir bien voulu souligner le
fait que nous étions pleinement
mobilisés dans ce 101e département
français dans
lequel nous sommes exposés à une crise
hydrique absolument sans précédent je
juste en deux lignes 54 heur de tour
d'eau ça veut dire que pendant 54 heur
de suite les maoraaises et les Maoris
n'ont pas
d'eau et après on ouvre l'eau pendant
18h depuis le 2 septembre premier
déplacement que j'ai pu faire n sommes
très précisément en production à 7500 m
C en plus d'eau par jour les besoins
c'est très simple c'est 43000 m CB par
jour il y a pas d'eau comme vous le
savez parce que réchauffement climatique
est là fait qu'en fait les deux grandes
réserves sont vides et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons le 2 septembre
décideré de de donner à la population la
plus fragile 51000 personnes de l'eau en
bouteille et depuis hier à l'ensemble de
la population j'ai dit à l'instant 7500
m en plus par jour nous avons développé
trois choses en plus une campagne de
forage sans
précédent je rappelle quand même à toute
fin utile qu' entre 2017 et 2022 il y
avait 6 millions d'euros payés par
l'État provisionné pour lequel il y a
pas le moins de forage qui a été fait
quand même qu'on dise un peu comment ça
s'est passé et là depuis le 2 septembre
2023 le 3è est en cours une campagne de
10 est
programmé une usine de dénalisation et
l'objet d'un appel d'œuv qui est en
cours d'analyse il devra retrouver une
situation normale si la pivométrie est à
la
hauteur je pense en février mars 2024 et
en tout cas une autonomie de production
d'eau pas avant mars 2025 voyz je vous
donne un tableau absolument sans
concession mais nous mettons nous
finançons tout à la fin du 31 décembre
ce
sera près de 97 millions d'euros qui ont
été financés par l'État à Mayotte en lu
plat des
collectivités alors évidemment ça a des
conséquences comme le sénateur t a très
bien dit sur plan sécuritaire déjà la
rentrée des classes c'est bien passé
c'est bien passé parce que une
protection totale a été faite c'est
volonté du MIN de
l'intérieuréducation nationale votre
serviteur pour faire en sorte que l'on
protège nos enfants qui vont à l'école
sachant qu'il sont à l'école une matinée
sur deuxon a des problèm
d'infrastructure comme vous le savez
elle s'est bien placée à l'hôpital MAM
faut en dire un mot parce que là encore
les forces de sécurité sont là pour
permettre au personnel soignant
d'assurer sa mission il y a eu des
moments très difficiles des des cars qui
transportent des personnels soignant qui
ont été cayassé a provoqué droit de
retrait j'ai rencontré à plusieurs
reprises ces délégations de salariés
parce que c'est indispensable de le
faire et n commen à retrouver une
situation un peu plus normale mais
naturellement il y a l'opération qui
avait été lancée par géréralmanin sur
lesquell nous irons au bout nous avons
plus de 680 bidon ville qui ont été rasé
mais on sait que c'est œuvre de longue
haleine et et cette ptée d'insécurité et
sur place nous avons pas moins de C
escadrons gendard mobile C sur les 22
dont je parlais qui étaient engagé
complètement à l'échelle du pays et bien
sûr d'autres forces de sécurité
intérieure qui ont été déployé un peu
plus de 1200 personnels j'ai bien
entendu la remarque lesgal crimogène
donc sur la doctrine je rrai ça
naturellement avec le Milie de
l'Intérieur j'attirerai son attention
sur les propos du sénateur mais puisque
vous faites référence monsieur le
sénateur aux événements grave qui se
sont produit il y a quelques jours une
gendarme a été fortément
blessée on peut pas laisser les forces
de l'ordre comme cela impunément se
faire encercler faire cayasser se faire
tirer dessus donc nous déployons tous
les moyens avec mesure mais il est des
moments où il fallait trouver des
solutions de désencerclement qui ont
conduit à l'usage des armes dont vous
parlez tout à l'heure mais sachez je
prends l'engagement devant la commission
devant le président que regarderez cela
avec les min d'intérieur de façon
extrêmement pré prise donc nous mettons
les moyens humains
euh et nous comprenons bien que la crise
de l'eau est d'autres crises parce qu'à
maotte c'est la rencontte de plusieurs
crises j serai je serai d'ailleurs à
nouveau présent la semaine prochaine à
Mayotte pour avancer avec les élus que
je remercie de nous accompagner au
quotidien parce que c'est œuvrees
difficile monsieur cateur m'ava
également interrogé sur les questions
lié au logement alors je rappelais tout
à l'heure initialement que sur la
fameuse ligne budgétaire unique inter
revenenue au niveau de 2013 on a eu des
sous-consommations ces sousconsommations
elles sont dus au fait qu'on a des
déficites d'ingéérie ça me permettra de
répondre à la dernière question du du
président de la commission je répondrai
très précisément puisque question qui
m'a immédiatement interpellé donc je
suis arrivé au responsabilité on a
plusieurs sujets on a à la fois des
manques d'ingéerie on a des fois du
déseres foncier on a la fois des manques
d'opérateur même si à Mayot on a un
opérateur public qui marche plutôt bien
je pense que sénateur T qui connaiss C
parfaitement bien le le sa quand même
sur les logements je vous donne les
chiffres on éta à 6209 en 2019 on été
monté à 10815 en 2021 et là à nouveau on
a eu une baisse en 2022 à 7208
pourtant on a pris des décisions au-delà
des d'ugmentation budgétaire dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure on a la fameuse
norme RUP qui va arriver région
ultrapériphérique qui va remplacer la
norme ce qui sera un élément de
compétitivité je crois très important et
puis on a en Guyane mais c'était pas
directement la question liée à Mayot les
fem besoin opération d'intérêt national
et qui permettront je crois d'être plus
présent et le frafu vous savez qui est
un fond qui est indispensable pour les
aménagements urbain et sur l'extension
du champ permettra je crois d'ê plus
efficace donc on progresse même si en
matière de logement il y a une crise
exagonale et une crise ultramarine et
d'ailleurs un sénateur qui vient de
m'interroger un député vont se voir
confier une mission gouvernementale sur
les questions du logement dans les
territoir ultramarin parce que c'est
important que l'on soit en capacité
d'apprécier d'appréhender la situation
du logement dans ce territoire
ultramarin parce que vous savez qu'il y
a un nombre de niches fiscal qui existe
à la clé et que on ne fasse pas une
refondte de nich fiscale sans même en
mesurer les incidences les conséquences
et qu'on ait les outils les plus adaptés
à la situation un peu particulière que
nous vivons donc voilà je crois vous
avoir répondu à de façon assez complète
ces questions ensuite vous m'avez
interrogé sur le filet de sécurité pour
les communes alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
un filet de sécurité qui a été mis en
place en 2022 vous aviez le bon chiffre
avz par de 14 millions d'euros c'est
vrai 19 communes qui ont noté
bénéficiires c'est encore vrai et il est
vrai que les communes qui sont
bénéficiaires des fameux quum dont je
parlais tout à l'heure n'étaient pas
éliggiible mais là pardonnez-moi c'est
le Sénat qui a voté contre l'amendement
qui avait été proposé donc peut-être que
on va y revenir mais en tout cas je sais
qu'il y a quatre communes très
précisément qui ont fait des avances qui
ONU des accomtes et on regardera comment
dans cette cas politique de quum on est
capable de trouver des solutions pour
mieux les aider et les quum d'ailleurs
vont un petit peu évoluer en 2000 24 non
pas simplement dans leur enveloppe parce
que j'ai a dit tout à l'heure qu'elle
augmenté puisque je l'ai expliqué que
c'était un acte de corresponsabilité
entre le gouvernement qui aider les
communes qui étaient en difficultés
financièr et les communes qui
acceptaient ce chemin et on aura une
aide progressive dans le temps sur 3 ans
je rappelle que le Corum il est signé
pour 3 années il est doté de 2,1 million
d'euros donc je crois que c'est quand
même quelque chose de de relativement
intéressant enfin sur les les normes
parceque vous m'avez évoqué ce sujet des
normes donc il y a un travail qui qui va
être accompli un ancien sénateur prés
dans du département du
Loiret avait beaucoup travaillé sur les
normes dans cette maison avec un rapport
excellent d'ailleurs qui malheureusement
est resté comme souvent pas suffisamment
exploré c'était éc deiger donc j'ai
j'avais regardé évidemment ce travail a
beaucoup d'intérêt donc on va conduire
et j'aurais besoin un moment ou un autre
que que on puisse avancer parce que on
peut pas considérer que les territoires
ultramarins doivent être traités comme
les territoires hexagonal d'ailleurs la
première ministre a pris des engagements
là-dessus et je rappelle qu' un élément
nouveau c'est que deavant il n'y a plus
une loi qui sortira sans qu'il y ait pas
une déclinaison ultramarine différente
vous connaissez tous la loisan je
rappelle qu'il y a un décalage qui a été
permis dans les territoires ultramarins
sinon c'est double peine peut pas être
toujours être très loin de tout ne pas
avoir les tils de production d'être dans
une dépendance économique très forte
être soumis à à des importations donc
toujours plus majeures avoir des
difficultés de matériaux je regarde la
sénatrice de de Saint-Bart et
Saint-Martin c'est quand même très
difficile lorsqu'on est loin donc vous
voyez qu'on essaie là encore d'être au
plus près et d'apporter des des
solutions donc voilà Monsieur sénateur
je crois que je ai répondu à V question
et si naturellement je l'avais pas fait
de façon complète je reviendrai bien sûr
madame la sénatrice cueran alors j'ai
bien
noté le fait que vous intéressez à
l'état territorial mais madame permettez
de et vous l'avez très bien dit dans
votre propos moi vous savez j'ai regardé
la baisse des effectifs parce qu'il y
avait des noms différents des acronymes
différents entre 2007 2012 2012 2017 et
en fait ont baissé l'armature et
l'armure de l'état de façon quotidienne
on l'a vécu moi dans une ville sous
préfecture j'ai vu comment les choses se
sont dégradées donc là je l'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure on est en train de de
remettre des moyens entre 2012 et 2017
c'est 2500 équivalent en plein dans les
préfectures 2500 équivalent en plein
dans les préfectures et encore je parle
des préfecture mais il y a d'autres
services de l'État regardez ce que sont
devenus les dral moi je suis dans une
région lesquel la plupart des services
techniques sont rattrachés à la dral
Normandie parce que on est un peu
malheureusement
déshabillé donc on est en train
d'inverser tout cela et évidemment le
chemin pour le réempranter dans l'autre
sens ça va prendre un peu de temps donc
sur ces ba effectifs vous avez raison je
crois qu'on on met un peu de moyen
peut-être
devrait-on j'entends mettre plus mais au
moins accordez-moi qu'avec les 350 lo
programmés on va avancer fr surétude
sécurisé je le disais un peu tout à
l'heure on est passé de 60 jours 70
jours même voyz moi je suis à 150 km de
Paris il a beaucoup de Parisiens qui
venaient le weekend he faire les titres
sécurisés on va être à 15 jours donc 15
jours c'est quand même un objectif très
important et avec l'objectif qui avait
été fixé par la première ministre à
l'époque c'était d'atteindre les 20
jours alors je sais qu'il y a encore
quelques endroits avec des petits
éléments disparat mais sachez bien qu'on
va suivre cela il faut qu'on passe tous
partout sous le cyle des 20 jours ça
demande d'ailleurs un engagement des
communes moi j'ai eu quelques
difficultés j'ai pu le voir dans ma
région par exemple à faire en sorte que
les communes se mobilisent je sais pas
si cétait le cas toutes les communes de
l'agglomération oranaise par exemple
mais donner du temps former trouver des
locaux adapter justement quelquefois
même le les temps de présence des agents
pour permettre d'apporter le meilleur
service public nous sommes là et on met
100 million d'euros à la clé pour cette
année 2024 donc je crois que c'est
important et enfin vous me parlez de
bilan de la certification des des
comptes pour les les collectivités
territoriales je crois qu'il y a eu des
des progressions considérables sur C la
qualité des compte hein je pense que le
bilan que fait par le gouvernement 2023
l'a montré ce qu'on souhaiterait c'est
que on soit en capacité d'avoir une
généralisation alors on pourra pas le
faire à marche forcée on se propose
d'atteindre cet objectif en 2026 donc ça
laisse le temps aux collectivités
territoriales de faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse demain avoir ses comptes
certifiés qui quand même un
à la fois d'ailleurs de transparent
vis-à-vis des concitoyens et qui sont
sur la responsabilité des élus des mères
en particulier je crois que c'est la MO
des choses et mais le fait de donner
comme objectif 2026 ça permet je crois
de trouver un chemin qui protégera parce
que ça demande du temps d'adaptation les
changements de nomenclature quand on les
a vécu c'est pas très simple lorsqu'on
est derrière le clavier pour tout
changer c'est un peu de boulot hein j'ai
l'occasion de de faire cela en tant
qu'élu local donc voilà en tout cas ce
bilan de la certification des comptes et
du moins cette volonté politique de
porter cette certification des comptes
et bien c'est la nôtre et sachez bien
que nous irons au bout alors madame
Dumont vous m'avez interrogé mais je je
savez pas que vous aez m'interrogé
là-dessus mais vous avez pu comprendre
dans mon propos liminire que ayant été
marqué dans dans ma vie locale aussi par
des drames il a des incendies que tous
les moyens d'observance de surveillance
doivent être au rendez-vous alors sur
les canadaers je vais vous donner les
CHR très Pr parce que vos questions
étaient extrêmement précises vous avez
donné les dates et c'est tout à fait
juste je veux pas vous contredire ce que
vous avez dit est juste deux Canada en
2027 2028 nouveau je vais venir aux
anciens de Canadair post 2030 et 12
Canadair nouveaux
euh post 2030 ça c'est les nouveaux non
mais c'est très loin et pendant ce temps
on fait quoi vous avz observé tout à
l'heure je suis intervenu en vous disant
que on mettait des moyens pour louer
donc on va louer voilà nous allons Lou
louer 10 hélicos bombardierers d'eau
dans la période intermédiaire parce que
on n pas la compé la capacité technique
je vais pas vous raconter des histoires
c'est comme vous êtes dans une région
dans laquelle l'aéronautique vous
connaissez par cœur peut-être
probablement mieux que moi entre la date
de commande de l'avion et la livraison
il y a toujours un temps absolument
incompressible on a tellement attendu
évidemment les Canadiens on les a fait
vieillir c'est superbe c'est merveilleux
les bombardiers de ha ça nécessite des
entretiens encore plus plus fin parce
que il y a des problèmes fonction assez
assez important avec ce genre d'appareil
donc voilà donc en attendant donc oui le
renouvellement est lancé à une cadence
dont je peux comprendre et en plus ça
aurais dû dire que malheureusement on a
un problème majeur on n pas quasiment
plus de fabricant en Canada que vous
connaissez un problème de compéten
technique et on voit d'ailleurs pour
d'autres éléments quand vous regardez
les métos c'est la même difficulté
command métro aujourd'hui il est livré
dans 5 ans et 6 ans c'est tout va bien
et on a tellement baissé l'armure à un
moment où un autre on n' pas de
consortium suscepti de porter cela mais
en tout cas les engagements du ministre
sont là je tiens à vous le dire sur
l'amendement gouvernemental vous avez eu
raison c'est pas vous raconter que vous
avez dit quelque chose qui était faux
c'est parfaitement vrai 180 millions
d'euros j'ai bien entendu votre
préconisation ser enregistré au
procèsverbal de faire en sorte queon
narrive pas comme
cela avec un amendement qui vienne le
plus tardivement possible c'est vrai que
180 millions d'euros et je répond en
même temps à Nathalie de latre oui cette
volonté de Libourne elle est là oui
c'est en 2024 c'est là oui les crédits
sont inscrits euh au-delà de la volonté
au-delà de l'exence la réalisation verra
justement son éclosion dès 2024 donc
pour revenir sur la ventilation euh des
fameux 180 millions d'euros donc la 4è
unité c'est 45 millions d'euros 45
millions d'euros le pacte capacitaire
c'est 39 millions d'euros et les
canadaers c'est une somme de 32 millions
qui renvoie au à l'intervention que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure à la demande que euh
mais a été faite sur la cybersécurité
comme ça ça me permet de de répondre à
Nathalie de
lâre pardon peut-être je pas répondu non
non non pardon madame
ministre je répondre je suis là j'ai
tout mon temps Madame euh ce réseau de
coopération entre services donc c'est
euh oui c'est le HD DSN qui est
responsable mais demandé la S sur la
cybersécurité l'autorité est bien
rattachée à mation donc je tiens à vous
le le confirmer et que naturellement en
matière de cybersécurité la
formation des personnels ultra compétent
continuera d'accélérer d'avancer
d'ailleurs avec le m du numérique je
crois savoir que là encore il y a des
points de rencontre de coordination pour
monter en puissance en effectif parce
que vous savez que cette compétition
aussi est liée à l'intelligence
artificielle donc il y a ce lien étroit
qui est en train de de se réaliser et en
tout cas euh croyez bien que cette
notion de cybersécurité elle est non
seulement indispensable mais on doit la
conforter je crois que les moyens sont
sur la table pour probablement toujours
aller plus vite mais c'est une étape
importante qui est franchie en 2024 et
sur l'IC c'est 18 millions en 2024 je
tenais à le préciser ce qui permet de de
répondre complètement à Nathalie de sur
les M nageurs sauvteurs euh je vais
annoncer à natthalie delat vous savez
que lorsque vous êtes ministre en charge
des outremère vous vous êtes occupé des
RSMA bien et dans le cadre de la
formation de mes jeunes RS qui au bout
de 8 mois on leur a appris je crois
beaucoup de choses je vais proposer qu'
soit des bafas soit des béanes premier
degré parce que BnsA c'est autre chose
c'est BR national ça de étapes j'ai géré
une piscine étant plus jeune donc voil
c'est pour ça que je connais un petit
peu C des métier on a un déficit
considérable il faut profiter de l'élan
Jeux Olympiques je vois d'ailleurs
général Pelou bientôt et je vais lui
vendre ses formations complémentaires et
en tout cas moi si on peut les prjeter
dans les territoires j'en serais très
heureux d'avoir la maîtrise de
fondamentaux comme on le donne dans ces
jeunes du RMA de leur permettre d' avoir
un diplôme d'animateur de passer le
permis de conduire on a 87 % de réussite
sur le permis de conduire dans le
casadre des RSMA d'avoir pour ceux qui
le veulent sur la base du volontariat un
béane parce que c'est tout à fait
compatible et également le brevet
national de securis donc voyez qu'on va
leur donner un panel de formation qui
sera je crois un début de passeport pour
la vie donc j'entends bien
euh c'est une vraie question on a beau
mettre des primes à la clé avec des
collectivités parce que moi je l'ai fait
dans ma région on a essayé de former 50
baisane de surveillante baignade en
mettant en finançant complètement les
formations très difficile en tout cas je
crois qu'il faut qu'on colle tous les
uns et les autres collectivité
territoriale et que nous on donne une
impulsion en tout cas le ministère de
l'intérieur des AES donnera son
impulsion en proposant aux jeunes dans
le cadre justement comme je disais à
l'instant de ces
[Musique]
RSMA enfin pour le président buffet
alors là c'est une question qui est ch à
mon cœur parce que je disais tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président moi je ne
peux pas être la responsabilité d'un
ministère où on met trois fois plus de
temps à sortir un projet qu'ailleurs et
je leur en veux pas je les comprends ils
ont pas le soutiens technique et
l'ingénierie suffisante il y avait déjà
je rappelle dans lecium suite à l'appel
de Fort de France c'est tout par cœur il
y a eu ces F qui s'est réunis 72 mesures
réunie sous la Louette de la première
ministre et ces mesure d'ailleurs nous
avons un premier bilan d'état duum de
tous les territoires concernés jeudi et
vendredi et de déjà 10 million d'euros
avait été mis à la clé et comment ça se
passe nous passons par la FD le
recensements sont
fait naturellement dans les territoires
et en fonction des besoins des communes
on intervient on se dirige vers quelque
chose d'un peu plus formel à la main des
préfets et je vais proposer qu'il y ait
des équipes que l'on peut projeter sur
des durées 6 mois ça peut être un an ça
peut être 18 mois alors on va s'occuper
également de laadem du crema du BRGM de
la DGCL de la NCT enfin bref toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont en
compétence pour aider euh les élus de
territoire ultramarin en charge des
collectivités les maires bien sûr les
collectivités territoriales de façon à
ce que ce qui est possible et ce qui est
indispensable soit possible dans les
meilleurs délis parce que plus c'est
long et pu ça coûte cher c'est une forme
de découragement j'ai assisté dans
certaines grandes communes de de
territoire ultramarin à constaté
malheureusement que des projets étaient
attendus depuis 10 ans donc nous pour
les hexagonaux ça peut paraître quand
même assez compliqué à accepter donc
sachez qu'on va déployer des moyens
considérable on se devrait être en
mesure à la fin du mois de janvier j'ai
déjà vu les acteurs à plusieurs reprises
euh d'avoir cette projection et je
réunirai d'ailleurs tous les préfets
dans le mois de janvier pour voir avec
eux comment ê le plus efficace avec les
associations des maires mais l'ont
demander dans chacun des déplacements
donc je seraai très heureux de pouvoir
rendre compte au Sénat je verrai
d'ailleurs devant la délégation aux
outremires bientôt et quelque chose qui
m'a été demandé en tout cas moi je vais
faire quelque chose de sur mesure c'est
pas moi qui va décider tout seul dans
mon bureau en aucun cas on le fera bien
sûr avec l'intérieur parce que ça
concerne Dominique fort puisqueon eu l'
occasion d'avoir cette conversation avec
elle il y a quelques semaines comment
demain on fait la transition énergétique
réussie comment on construit mieux
comment on les accompagne plus
rapidement parce qu' une complexité
folle quand vous regardez le problème du
du foncier je sais que vous connaissez
cette question que regarde en guyan ce
qui se passe il eu beau d'avoir la loi
les chimies on est loin encore du compte
si on veut avoir des disponibilités
foncières parce que pour construire par
définition faut du foncier et puis
deuxièmement on a le problème des des
matériaux dont je parlais tout à l'heure
donc c'est pour ça que l'adoption de la
norme RUP sera un élément de complément
une brique complémentaire c'est cas de
le dire j'utilise ce mot à dessin qu'on
soit plus efficace notre volonté c'est
de consommer ces crédits je ne peux me
satisfaire d'avoir des crédits qu'on ne
consomme pas juste un dernier mot si
mautoriser monsieur le Président pour
les fonds européens et je terminerai
l'astuce qui m'autoriser également là
nous étions un peu un peu les derniers
de la classe voilà disons-le on est
remonté assez fortement je vous invite à
regarder le taux de consommation dans
les territoires ultrarins qui a beaucoup
progressé c'est et je crois qu'on peut
s'appliquer ça à l'Hexagone c'est
toujours dommage de faire avir des
enveloppes et le dégagement d'office qui
repart à Bruxelles donc en tout cas
cette demande d' gééie et je suis tout à
fait à l'écoute de ce que me dira le
Sénat l'Assemblée va apporter sa
contribution je serai devant le groupe
dans quelques jours ici même et prêt à
entendre vos préconisations pour que
l'on soit capable d'être les plus
efficace possible pour mieux accompagner
les territoires ultraarin voilà madamees
messieurs les sénateurs peut-être un
dernier mot les violences sur les élus
euh puisque
question m'a été posée donc je rappelais
la loi du du 7 juillet je rappelais
aussi que ça y est on avait baissé le
seuil augmenté le seuil de 3500 à 10000
habitants pour la protection juridique
proposée pour les élus et et enfin je
rappelle qu'il y a des opérations de de
contact de proximité qui sont conduites
par la gendarmerie nationale pour faire
des sensibilisations de manière à ce que
rien ne reste impuni en tout cas moi
j'ai eu l'occasion à la demande de
géralmanin d' animer une Association des
Maires dans un département de ma région
et c'est ce message que j'ai déployé
relayé par les maires et là c'est vous
en particulier les sénateurs et les
maires doivent être doivent savoir que
nous ne laisserons rien passer croyez-le
bien les consignes très fermes ont été
donnés au commissariat ont été donnés au
gendarmerie de proximité et en lien très
étroit avec la place beauovau de manière
ce que toucher à un maire toucher à un
élu c'est touché à la République on le
sera pas
faire monsieur le ministre M présidente
ou je vous remercie non peut-être
simplement parce que soit soit ma
question était mal formulée soit je n'ai
pas compris votre réponse peut-être pour
préciser ma question portait bien sur la
certification des des comptes de
l'identité numérique dans quelques
communes volontaires aujourd'hui et non
sur la certification des comptes
budgétaire et et comptbl des
collectivités territoriales mais on
interpellera les les services pour avoir
les les données plus précises moi je
souhaitais revenir sur les propos que
vous avez eu à la fois sur les normes et
sur le fond vert d'abord parce que
effectivement on est voilà ça fait des
années qu'on le dit face à une inflation
de norme y compris avec une
contradiction individuelle et collective
que nous avons toutes et tous
c'est-à-dire d'un côté à toujours
vouloir apporter plus de sécurisation à
l'initiative publique qui inévitablement
génère des normes et en même temps
demandant à ce qu'il y a moins de normes
pour faciliter l'initiative publique sur
les territoires donc je je le pointe
mais je je crois que c'est effectivement
en tout cas une vraie question à
travailler à travailler avec beaucoup
intelligence parce que dans le ralbol
des merses il y a aussi cela il y a bien
évidemment et je n'y reviens pas vous
venez de finir vos propos sur sur ça
toute la question des des agressions
menaces de de différents ordres et de
diff et et heureusement ce n'est pas
systématiquement le pire à l'encontre
des élus mais en tout cas qui se génér
mais c'est aussi un sentiment parfois
euh de oui un peu d'une camisole qui qui
empêche toute action toute initiative
par une multiplication de normes qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas que le fruit de
de de la loi et qui qui viennent de
différentses secteurs activités et
cetera sur le fond vert alors on dirait
c'est peut-être plus à à Monsieur Béchu
qu'il faut poser la la question mais moi
je je veux attirer l'attention parce que
nous avions eu le débat ici en
commission des lois quand nous avions
Audié auditionné Christophe Béchu il y a
à peu près un an ça devait être d'une
grande simplicité d'une grande facilité
je crois qu'on peut se le dire et
j'entends les efforts budgétaire que
vous entendez mettre pour cette année
c'est pas tout à fait d'une grande
simplicité euh dans la formalisation des
dossiers à déposer et puis on se rend
compte qu'il y a plusieurs volets donc
on sait pas et comment dans dans quel
cadre on se rend compte également euh et
puisqu'on parle de norme et de
simplification que ce qui est quand même
exceptionnel dans dans notre pays c'est
qu'il faut faire un dossier qui peut
être commun des etr ou ou des ciles mais
il en faut un autre différent encore sur
le fond vert je vous passe quand même
les demande d'expertise de gain
énergétique sur des bâtiments des années
80 sur lesquels il y a eu aucun travaux
et donc tout le monde sait aujourd'hui
c'est des passoirs énergétiques donc on
demande outre le cout que ça ça génère
on demande des expertises dont on sait
très bien que le moindre les moindres
travaux qui vont être faits vont être
performants dans les gains énergétiques
donc moi je vous invite quand même aussi
à là pour le coup à revoir côté état
peut-être un peu de simplification et
puis moi j'attire votre attention
c'est-à-dire que nous avons dans un
certain nombre de
départements des dossiers où justement
parce que comme c'était censé être
tellement simple et facile il y a eu
pour le coup un très bon service àprè
vente fait par les préfets et les
sous-préfets peut-être d'ailleurs un peu
trop et avec quelques déconvenus qui
sont tombés au mois de juin et au mois
de juillet sur un certain nombre de
communes qui euh n'ont pas été éligibles
sur les dossiers en tout cas qui
nécessitent interprétation est-ce que
c'est par manque de financement est-ce
que c'est parce que ça rentrait pas dans
la bonne case au bon endroit je rentre
même pas dans ce sujetlà je je je crois
qu' effectivement c'est en tout cas un
fond qui peut amener du souffle amener
de de de la capacité à faire dans dans
dans dans nos départements encore
faut-il que que ça ne devienne pas avec
le temps une forme d'usine à gaz qui
empêcherait justement cette réactivité
et cette simplicité tant attendue et en
tout cas mise en avant il y a maintenant
1 an au au lancement du fond vert dans
dans le cadre du précédent projet de loi
de
finances merci madame monsieur vous
voulez la parole merci monsieur le
Président
euh la première chose madame la
sénatrice sur les
normes je pense que lorsqu'on a été élu
local à un moment ou un autre
franchement et qu'on y a été
confronté il y a un vrai sujet on va
pass se raconter l'histoire et j'ai
insisté tout à l'heure pour dire et je
pense que la demande la la volonté de la
première ministre de de faire en sorte
qu'on ne traite pas les territoires
ultramarins comme on traite l'Hexagone
est aussi un élément de réponse voilà je
voulais souligner donc qu' a Eric ver
qui va seev voir confier une très belle
mission je pense que son expertise de
président de la commission des finances
dansci du budget et surtout d'élus local
le qualifie me semble-t-il pour faire un
rapport qui ne sera pas un rapport de
complaisance et qui
permettra d'éclairer le gouvernement sur
les choix qu'il aura à faire en tout cas
je suis pas inqu une seconde
et je crois que ça sera outil
indispensable pour être plus efficace
par rapport à ces normes souvent
incomprises et d'autant plus que nous
lesateurs enfin je me sens encore un
peuiciateur quelquefois on a légiféré
alors que l'application même n'était pas
toujours parfaite au Parlement et
qu'elle pouvait lêtre imposé dans les
communes voilà donc vraiment je suis
tout à fait confiant sur les fonds verts
j'étais pas encore miné j'étais député
lorsque je suis allé faire le tour des
communes pour expliquer comment ça
marchait accordez-moi qu' a eu beaucoup
de souplesse qui été donné on a rempli
les dossiers en ligne façon extrêmement
simple je l'ai fait à plusieurs reprises
et il y a eu une vraie consommation et
sa qu'il y a eu des déceptions pourtant
on a mis 2 milliards d'euros sur la
table je vous ai dit qu'on allait mettre
2 milliards 4 l'année prochaine 2
milliards 5 pardon donc c'est un effort
substantiel et il est vrai que euh
certains sont arrivés un peu plus tard
mais malheureusement c'est tous les
appels à projet ça se passe comme ça
faut toujours être un vous savez très
bien que lorsqu'on est local il faut
toujours avoir trois projets dans le
tiroir de être prêt à les sortir le
moment venu c'est un gage d'efficacité
pour les pour faire en sorte queon
puisse avancer mais quand même sur euh
les autres outils de ta descil j'entends
bien ce que vous me dites mais il va y
avoir des des instructions qui vont
venir d'après ce que dit le cabinet
Dominique fort et donc je félicite si ça
va dans dans ce sens-là c'est qu'il
puisse avoir des instructions communes
sur tous ces outil nous on arrive à le
faire dans le département j'imagine qu
parlementaire vous le faites c'est qu'on
voit comment on fait la meilleure
articulation possible les 2/3 c'est
plutôt plutôt des des projets un petit
peu plus petits comme vous savez il y a
la r des 150000 € moins de 150000 € avec
une décision euh qui est un peu à la
main de l'État et puis c'est puis les
grands projets par la fameuse commission
de TR et puis les décil avec quelquefois
en plus il y a des fléchages comme vous
savez c'est une enveloppe régionale qui
est dé localisée qui est envoyé sur les
départements en tout cas il vaoir des
instructions qui seront de plus en plus
simultané je peux vous dire pour dessux
qui ont été portés à ma connaissance et
je crois que ça c'est un gage
d'utilisation
importante et puis Dominique fort a
lancé quelque chose auquel je sais
qu'elle est très attachée c'est la
simplification administrative là-dessus
parce que je crois qu'il faut qu'on on
simplifie les choses qui a une note de
présentation très bien un budget
consolidé parfait mais D nécrire 10
pages certainement pas c'est le sens de
de la de ce que ma collègue ministre et
en tout cas elle trouvera avec moi un
avocat général permanent parce que j'ai
tellement croulé sousement de compliqué
que plus ça sera efficace et puis
d'ailleurs quelque part je termine juste
là-dessus c'est une forme de crédibilité
vis-à-vis d'action publ parce que on
demande souvent est-ce que ça sert je
monte un dossier parce que parce que
voilà et y a un moment il y a eu
beaucoup d'appels à manifestation
intérêt là je reconnais que le
gouvernement par les décisions qui ont
été prises au du ministère d'intérieur
ont plutôt eu tendance à simplifier les
choses parce que lorsque vous avez trop
d'appels à manifestation d'intérêt dans
différents compartiments ministériels
qui s' s'entassent les un a dessus des
autres au bout d'un moment on ne s'y
retrouve plus et ça c'est là encore ça
nuit encore à l'efficacité locale voilà
et enfin sur la certification des
comptes vous avez fait référence moi je
crois que c'est bien qu'on a ver mais
pas à marche forcée sur la base du
volontariat mais qu'on arrive à cette
qualité euh de certification des comptes
qui est aussi je disais tout à l'heure
un gage de confiance vis de concitoyens
qui sont toujours plus demandeurs et
c'est normal puis les moyens numériques
sont là donc ils peuvent tout consulter
et le fait d'avoir un agement à un
moment ou un autre mais moi je prends
pas du tout ombrage du fait que il
puisse y avoir une observance qui soit
faite sur telle ou telle disposition
même s'il y a une administration des
collectivités territoriales comme dis
les maires sont aussi des agents de
l'État par définition donc on doit comme
on vit aussi de beaucoup de de
financement public et et bien rendre des
comptes et rendre des comptes c'est un
gage de démocratie et moi je tiens à
cette démocratie merci beaucoup madame
la sénatrice merci Monsieur le Ministre
euh j'avais une question malheureusement
je l'ai
oublié
laquelle vos propos m'avit avaent attiré
mon attention oui c'était sur la
protection des maires et le statut des
élus madame la ministre madame Ford nous
avait annoncé un texte savez-vous à
quelle date il sera effectivement déposé
sachant que nous avons voté ici il y a
pas très longtemps au mois d'octobre un
texte sur la protection également des
élus ici une PPL et dont on nous dit on
croit comprendre qu'elle sera présentée
également à l'Assemblée nationale au
mois de
janvier alors quand est-il votre cabinet
va nous dire les dates précises les HE
président autorise une incertitude dans
la date parce que mais je vois que je
vais probablement avoir un renfort qui
va me gagner du temps euh comme vous
vous savez monsieur le président les les
les textes par moment on me dit que les
travaux de la CNDL c'est le 7 novembre
et que le texte devrait être dans le 6
prers mois de l'année 2024 d'accord oui
moi je je vous faire clair le
teximmigration arrive le 11 décembre a
priori j'imagine qu'il a une petite
trêve de Noël ici comme se passe à
l'Assemblée donc je sa pas si nous
aurons terminé n sommes pas comme vous
savez dans tempatif
programmé
avez que les les par définition le
Parlement est libre de l'organisation de
ses travaux donc il y a eu une
concomitance à la fois d'udition à
l'Assemblée au Sénat c'est pour ça que
je suis tout à fait transparent le
ministre nous avait informé de son
indisponibilité récemment du fait qu'il
était retenu à l'Assemblée nationale ah
bon bien donc merci monsieur le
Président en tout cas oui vous dire que
début janvier on
a petit peu de texte qui arrive à
l'Assemblée on a également le projet de
loi maotte sur lequel on aura discuter
avec les parlementaires donc voilà je
pense que le calibre de 6 premiers mois
de l'année 2024 me me paraît plutôt bien
sachant qu'on on a également un texte
sur le logement est encore préparation
lo programmation agricole donc voilà
c'est normal chacun des départements
ministériels essayer de voir comment il
peut prendre rang mais je prends pas
trop de risque en disant que le premier
semestre 2024 devrait permettre monsieur
président d'accueillir ce texte dont
vous parliez à
l'instant parfait merci pas d'autres
question reste à vous remercier Monsieur
le Ministre de votre temps passer devant
la commission très
bientôt